if I took every single water molecule in
this bowl and lined them all up end to
end single file how long would that line
stretch 100 meters a mile 10 miles no
this many molecules of water placed end
to end would stretch a light year and
that fact is what inspired us to create
the light year bottle free yourself from
the Yoke of three-dimensional space
don't drink volume drink length how many
light years of water can you suck
there's other unusual amounts as well
for example filled to here the entire
bottle weighs about as much as a warm
human heart still beating in your hand
why would you want to know this kind of
stuff well because I know you and you
don't just live a life of action you
live a life of the Mind
and you're weird this bottle and our die
that only rolls one number are both
coming in the same curiosity box later
this year when it all arrives at your
door your eyes will fall upon it and by
the way this is the amount of water in
two adult human eyes